Or, un album où il chante, lui
Philippe Ouïmet a beaucoup aimé.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Au début de la pandémie,
Daniel Bélanger était incapable
d'écrire quoi que ce soit.
À défaut de pouvoir voyager,
le printemps venu,
il a composé certaines
de ses plus belles chansons.
♪ Voilà qu'en nous
c'est comme en mai ♪
DANIEL BÉLANGER,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- J'ai eu envie de quelque chose
de lumineux, et on a beau
avoir le projet d'en faire
un album lumineux, il faut
commencer et on ne sait pas
si la lumière va persister.
♪ Le jour s'éveille
sur ma voiture ♪
♪ Et sur toutes
mes courbatures ♪
- Et la lumière fût
dans lesdans lesdans lesdans les
de Daniel Bélanger.
Encore une fois, il a
lui-même réalisé son album
dont le titre, "Mercure en mai",
est tombé du ciel.
- "Mercure en mai" est un titre
complétement superficiel.
(rire)
C'est-à-dire que j'aimais
l'image et "Mercure" est un mot
que j'aime. La substance,
le mercure, j'en ai tenu quand
j'avais 9 ans dans ma main,
qui était du métal liquide.
Ça m'a intrigué toujours.
Et comme je voulais faire un
album lumineux avec celui-ci,
Mercure étant la planète
la plus proche du soleil.
Je me suis dit : Ah! Yé!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un vent de renouveau
souffle sur Daniel Bélanger,
qui a changé de maison de disque
et qui est de plus en plus
présent sur les réseaux soci
Ses nouvelles channt
d'amour sans artifice, d'un
vivre-ensemble nécessaire et de
cette violence qui nous entoure.
♪ ♪ ♪
- J'ai composé les deux
dernières chansons dans
les deux premières semaines
de l'agression des Russes sur
l'Ukraine, ce qui rte
que j'ai mis des bruits de
bouche qui imitent des bombes
et des mitraillettes
sur "Soleil levant".
Et "Je ne tuerais plus jamais
qu'avec des fleurs",
c'est quand tu reçois des
fleurs... tu me tues
quand tu m'offres des fleurs.
Je me suis dit : Ane
bonne façon de tuer les gens...
Ah! les tuer d'amour
avec des fleurs.
♪ Sèche tes pleu
sèche tes pleurs ♪
♪ Je t'en prie
- Il y a 30 ans déjà,
Daniel Btrait
dans nos oreilles
avec un premier album.
Son "Mercure en mai" est
un de ses meilleurs. Il nous
rappelle son chef-d'oeuvre
"Rêver mieux", mais
aussi "L'Échec du matériel",
LE disque de l'année 2007.
rrêté de rrêté de rrêté de rrêtx
albums précédents, puis je me
suis dit : qu'est-ce que je
ferais si j'avais aucun album
avant, ce qui est impossible.
Qu'est-ce que je ferais sans
complexe? OK, je joue de la
guitare comme ça, bien je vais
jouer de la guitare comme ça.
J'aime ce clavier-là? Bien, je
vais faire avec lui. OK, est-ce
que ça ressemble à "Rêver
mieux", "L'échec du matériel",
"Nous"?
C'est moi.
♪ ♪ ♪
- "Mercure en mai" est
de la soixde la soixde la soixde
pour Daniel Bélanger
et pour ses admirateurs,
il est celui de l'authenticité.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
anada, Montréal.
- ♪ Il faut s'acc